I think we need a Bedroom class to
represent the bedrooms in our house.
Follow along with me.
Like we did before Ctrl-click on
the House folder, go to New File,
choose Cocoa Class, and
we'll call this class Bedroom.
And of course we want
the language to be Objective C.
Okay so now, what should
the properties of our bedroom be?
I'm going to give it a BOOL to represent
whether or not it has a privateBath.
And I also want to property to represent
which direction the window faces.
I like it when my bedroom window faces
east, so that I can see the morning sun.
What's a good way to
represent a direction?
If this were swift,
we definitely use an enum.
That's what we'll do here too, but
you'll notice that Objective C
enums are pretty minimalist
compared to Swift enums.
Enum definitions go at
the top of your header file.
The preferred way to create an enum
is using the NS_ENUM macro,
where NSInteger is the enum type and
direction is the enum name.
All enums in Objective C
are of type NSInteger.
Now that we've created our direction
enum, we can add the property
directionWindowFaces to
our Bedroom class.
And now that our Bedroom class is ready,
let's go back into the House.h file and
add a couple bedrooms to our house.
[SOUND] What's going on here?
Unknown type name bedroom.
Okay, even though they're
in the same project,
the house class can't see
the bedroom class right now.
We have to import it at
the top of the file like this.
Looks like that come to the compiler and
now we can use the bedroom class
from inside of the house class.